hello listen before i start i just want
to pay
a little bit of homage and also a
tribute to the guests that i had joined
me last week on this podcast
the feedback that i got from that
conversation for those that had the
resilience to listen for the full two
hours and if you haven't
i genuine genuinely implore you too
because
the value of that conversation and the
diversity of the topics we touched on i
genuinely believe are life-changing
i've reflected continuously throughout
this week on that conversation we
touched on everything from depression to
anxiety to burnout
and it's really developed to me you know
what one of the things they say is that
the teacher is the person in a classroom
that gets the most value from a
conversation and in that context
i as the interviewer who got to sit
there and listen and prod and think
through my own sort of selfish curiosity
i think i got the most value out of that
i certainly learned a ton
about myself the world and some of the
problems that i've had throughout my
life so if you haven't
and you do get the time i implore you to
go back and check out that episode
and in fact that episode has it's
inspired
this episode in many ways one of the
things that
you guys have said to me in my dms on
your stories
in the reviews everywhere my emails you
said to me one of the things you enjoy
most about this podcast
is when i'm a little bit more raw and
when i
i'm a little bit less scripted per se
not that i'm ever really that scripted
but when i'm a little bit more off the
cuff when i talk about my own anecdotes
my own life and my own stories and so
this
episode this chapter is going to be
exactly that
it's predominantly centered on my
anecdotes my diary is full of things
that have happened to me this week
personal stories from my friends and the
lessons that they've taught me the
lessons they've taught me about myself
about my life and about how to build a
better future
so without further ado i'm stephen
bartlett and this is the divers ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
so for the first point in my diary this
week i've literally just written means
to an end syndrome let me explain what i
mean
every single year i set myself the same
goal in february
and the goal is simple it's to get in
good physical shape and every year
thankfully
i achieved that goal until september
and by october my motivation to work out
to eat well and to be healthy
seems to transform from this like
tangible object that i can hold on to
to sand slipping through my hands by
january the following year
all hell has broken loose in my diet i'm
basically fat compared to how i usually
am
my my energy is lower my sleep isn't as
good i just don't
feel my best anymore then february comes
around again and march comes around
and i set myself the same goal to get in
shape and the cycle repeats itself
this has happened to me i'd say every
year for at least the last five years
in a row and i've not been able to
understand from a psychological
perspective
why this is happening and with all
things in life until you become
conscious of what's causing you to
behave the way that you are
you're merely just a puppet and the
puppet master
remains this unknown force this
experience you had at some point uh
you know a facet of your psychology one
that usually doesn't have your best
interests at heart one that usually
can't be trusted
a puppet master that certainly isn't
working for you
he's working for your insecurities or
for your for your ego
or for trauma that you've experienced
the same cycle unfortunately started to
repeat itself this year
i mean i started the year fat january
time i was pretty fat compared to how i
usually am
walking can feel the little rolls on my
belly shaking as i walk and i'm wearing
slightly baggier clothes
by august i was in the best shape of my
entire
life right because of an obsessive focus
on the gym i was going
seven days a week i was calorie counting
one day i did 5 000 calories
and by september my motivation started
as it always does to just fall away
i noticed that i wasn't charging my
apple watch anymore i noticed that i'd
started to miss
the gym i started to eat junk food again
this lasted for about two weeks this
year
but this time i started to be a bit more
conscious about it i told myself what i
was doing
and i started examining my own
psychology and saying literally saying
to myself
steve you're doing it that cycle is
repeating itself you're eating [ __ ]
you're lacking motivation
fortunately i've just written a whole
chapter on the topic of motivation for
my upcoming book
so i because of the research that i had
to do to write that chapter i
understand the psychological principles
and the forces at play that make someone
motivated or unmotivated and armed with
that
and my own sort of critical
self-analysis which i attained from
being more conscious
about what i was doing the fact that i
was eating junk food and i'd i could
feel my motivation waning
i finally understood why this is
happening to me
maybe maybe this is happening to me
isn't the best way to describe it why
i'm doing this to myself or not
doing things to myself that i should be
doing and
touchwood i finally overcome it it's
november
and i'm still working out for the first
time literally in my life i'm still
eating well and i'm still focused on my
health goals
and this is the first year ever that i
can remember in the last
five really in the last decade where
i've been just as committed to working
out
now and to being healthy in my entire
life
than i was during the summer so let me
tell you how i did this and let me tell
you what i understood
about my own motivation because i know
it's going to speak to you in your own
way
let me rewind every year around february
march i say the same thing to myself and
i set myself the same goal
let's just stop there right and take a
look at what i just said because there's
a real
clue in that first sentence why does
this goal pop up in march
the answer quite an obvious one because
summer is on the horizon
and you've got to ask yourself again
you've got to criticize yourself there
and say well why does
summer matter well because you know
summertime is a time where
we wear less clothes we're a little bit
more vulnerable our bodies are on show
more
and then you can ask yourself okay so
why is that relevant well it speaks to
the nature of my motivation
my motivation wasn't to work out it
wasn't to be healthy because i want
long-term health benefits or to or to
feel great about myself
as embarrassing as this is to admit my
motivation was so clearly
clearly to look good for
summer let's just break that down a
second
look good for summer looking good
as a goal is measured by just one thing
the public's opinion of me
ladies opinion of me that's what we call
an extrinsic external goal
success of that goal will be achieved
when the public think i look
good the next part of that sentence
right was for
summer the next part of my goal was for
summer which is a measurable
time frame so once summer is over
the job is done so the motivation behind
that goal was both extrinsic
and held within a time frame so when i
dropped that social media pic of me
topless in
mykonos or wherever i went this summer
mykonos and costa rica looking good
during summer and when i got the
compliments the likes the followers the
praise
and when summer passed unsurprisingly
so did my motivation job done my goal
my reason my why was attached to summer
and also public opinion
and both had been fulfilled so as i
pulled into october and i tried to find
the motivation to go to the gym it was
gone
going to the gym suddenly felt so
pointless to me and i had no idea why it
just did
even when i managed to get to the gym my
workout was quite honestly pathetic it
was short it was like
25 30 minutes of me predominantly
texting and i didn't know why
i just thought i wasn't feeling great
like you know like a boat that had
suddenly been
unanchored i was now just drifting
unconsciously without intention or real
motivation
or without conscious realization into
the winter months into bad habits into
fat steve
and the minute i realized this this year
i was able to completely
reset and sort of re-anchor my
motivation into things that were
intrinsically internally motivating and
without time frames
i set myself the goal of going to the
gym just because it makes me feel great
and because of the energy it gives me
and the positive impact it has on my
sleep
and because you know i love showing
myself how self-disciplined i am
i get a real weird feeling of joy by
going to the gym on a day when i feel
like
[ __ ] because for me that's kind of
overcoming my mind
right it's like beating um the the
negative
or the the weaker parts of my mind that
are trying to dissuade me from doing
something that's in line with my
long-term values
and honestly also people don't like to
say this but
the positive impact it has on my sex
life
i didn't really know how to say this
without sounding like a [ __ ] dick but
i have never been there in bed
and and just generally how good it makes
me feel
all year round all of these things have
no
finish line they're not extrinsically or
externally judged by the public
they're the opposite of the extrinsic
short-term goals i set myself in march
they're intrinsic
they are never ending they view life not
just as a bunch of recurring seasons but
as
one season one season from now until the
day that i die
the season of life and that that is the
season that it's incredibly valuable
and important to be healthy and
to look good for as james clear says you
know we tend to believe that we'll be
more successful or happy or prosperous
if we put more intensity into our lives
you know like the intensity that i
showed in march every year in the
lead-up to summer you know like crash
diets and sprinting towards our goals at
the expense of everything else
staying up for weeks and weeks and weeks
on end to revise for that exam
but the truth is we don't need intensity
if we have a little bit more consistency
had i just stayed in good shape in
september october november december and
january
if i just gone to the gym maybe twice or
three times a week throughout that
period and
avoided a bit of you know the junk food
which i binged on
um periodically through that period i
wouldn't even need the intensity for the
rest of the year i wouldn't need to
starve myself obsessive in my diet and
go to the gym
seven days a week sometimes twice a day
in fact
intensity for me is often a sign that we
lacked
consistency in the past and i think
and i've said this a couple of times in
this podcast before but until you know
right and this is not easy i'm gonna
make this sound like it's an easy thing
to do
but it requires the same sort of
critical self-analysis and
that i've demonstrated that what you
would have seen from what i just said is
i interrogated my rationale so i said
you know why does it why do i always get
motivated in february in march and then
i said
well because you know someone's around
the corner and then why does summer
matter well because other
you know extrinsic reasons and if you go
down that rabbit hole with humility
and with the attention of not defending
your ego but finding the truth
then you might understand what's
motivating you but until you know what's
motivating you
you won't know where you're going or why
you're going there or
who's steering the ship what force in
your life is steering that ship
and i'd predict that 99.9
of your motivations are misguided or
somewhat unconscious
you don't really know why you're doing
what you're doing i think most of the
time
you have no idea what the driving force
behind your behavior is the same applies
for me
but until you do until you have the
self-awareness and that humility you
need
to interrogate your thinking and the
lack of ego
to identify why you're doing what you're
doing whether it's superficial driven by
insecurities from your childhood
because you're seeking validation like i
was or other you will never actually be
in control of your life
something else is and if your goals are
extrinsic
someone else's okay so the next point in
my diary i've just written here
journey back to human let me explain
i find it so ironic but somewhat
unsurprising if i'm honest that most of
the new age techniques that were aimed
to sort of improve our mental health and
overall well-being are largely based on
old age principles of how our life used
to be tens of thousands of years ago
and in the process of writing my book i
i went back
over the last i'd say three decades to
see how humans and neanderthals lived
their lives
to understand why this is it's almost
like
as we developed as humans and as we
started to rely on agriculture and
farming and
we stopped living in our tribe it's like
we took a wrong turn
and we filled our lives with over
stimulation and with like alcohol
and caffeine and poor nutrition and
loneliness and convenience right and i
think
based on the alarming growth in mental
health conditions like depression
anxiety addiction and
even other conditions like loneliness
and i'd say purposefulness right
i think it's time to turn back and the
question
i guess i often i'm forced to ponder is
what is what is a human being what are
we
what are we meant to be if we take away
all of this social pressure
take away instagram and all of the noise
and all of the pressure to conform
what are we who are we and how are we
meant
to live and infrequently
i'll find myself trawling through google
as i did as i you know when i went over
to costa rica
and i spent the time in the jungle i
found myself trawling through google in
history
trying to understand humans and it's
unsurprising
that the natural lifestyle of humans
back then consists of everything that
therapists and nutritionists and mindset
coaches and psychologists
preach about when you're feeling like
[ __ ] today
let's start with probably the most
obvious it should be the most obvious
and it's definitely a one of the things
that's causing depression in a lot of
people
it's this lack of human connection back
then
10 000 years ago we lived in our tribes
surrounded by family and friends and
johanna hari who came on this podcast
and is actually coming back on this year
that's a little
exclusive for you wrote a life-shifting
book called lost connections on this
exact point and if there's ever a book
i've read in my life and i'm not here to
plug your hannah harry just for you know
because he comes on the podcast and
stuff like that
the reason he comes on this podcast is
because his book i'd say in the last
three years
has had the biggest single impact on how
i see the world right
the fundamental conclusion of that book
is we need each other
that is non-negotiable i i've read a
bunch of studies and i've seen a bunch
of ted talks on youtube
where they've done a study over a
century and they followed like a hundred
or a thousand people
and the people that don't establish
meaningful relationships in their lives
die earlier they get more sick and they
have a worse quality of life
i didn't used to think this stuff right
right i didn't think this was important
before
i mistakenly thought that if i got rich
really really rich everything else would
fall into place so when i at 18 years
old
my whole life was centered on this north
star which was getting filthy rich
at the expense of everything and i
sacrificed everything for that
and i i gotta be honest because this
that's what this podcast is for i felt
that loneliness
i didn't actually like weekends because
they were so empty for me
i didn't have anything to do i'd i'm
sure some of you can relate to this you
know
especially you hustle porn stars out
there that are running your businesses
weekends were just this big [ __ ] void
in my life
there was nothing to do so i just went
to the office my entire life at that
point when i was 18 19 20
was focused on money work business
and after developing this habit of like
forced
self-induced loneliness for about five
six or seven years
it had really really stuck i was a
self-diagnosed
recluse one that spent all of his time
in the office
on my laptop making more money even
though i already had more money than i
you know could ever possibly need
and at some point thankfully i realized
the
never-ending pointless insanity of my
situation
what was the point in having all of this
money and if i didn't have any
meaningful relationships to enjoy it
with
life is uh it's a multiplayer game it's
not a solo experience
and i i got to see how miserable
some of my quote unquote successful
friends were
by just being behind the scenes in their
life one of the i guess the positive
things that happened to me when i became
successful quote unquote was i made a
lot of successful friends and those
friends
in many cases were way ahead of me and
and what they did for me
is they showed me what my future would
look like if i carried on how i was
i got to see behind the scenes behind
their lamborghinis behind their mansions
and i realized that life had lied to me
you know of course progress and success
and striving towards
goals matter like of course right it's
it's made me fulfilled to some degree
but
not at the expense of all the other
things not the expensive meaningful and
frequent human connection
the other thing that i observe when i
when i sort of reflect on on
how our ancestors used to live is just
the sheer simplicity of their lives you
know they lived together in
in caves and these simple huts they were
hunters and gatherers they used
basic tools which they had made to track
and hunt birds and wild animals they
cooked
their prey around a campfire they fished
they collected berries and fruits and
nuts
their goals were so significantly more
intrinsic
and survival focused than ours are today
they were focused on taking care of
themselves
and one another a very simple life it's
a very simple purpose
without all of this [ __ ] [ __ ] that we
have today without instagram without
politics trump fearful news cycles
without
two hour work commutes right to get
between four white walls to lock
ourselves in a cubicle without stress
without
traffic without obsessive worrying and
notifications and emails and
inbox zero pressures and social
pressures and expectations of how your
life is meant to be going
without all of that [ __ ] a simpler life
which results in a simpler mind
which is so frequently the thing that
you know
psychologists and therapists prescribe
to all of us when we have illnesses
today to simplify our lives
but simplifying our lives seems to go
against
society's mandate that expects you to be
so much
that expects career success from you
that expects financial success
material possessions that expects
psychological perfection that expects
physical fitness and health
social status to push yourself out of
your comfort zone to climb the ladder
to have perfect relationships at the
same time to demonstrate the perfect
behavior all while living living in a
healthy perfect
clear mentally stable mind this level of
like obsessive perfection
and you know accomplishment seeking and
validation hunting
isn't conducive with simplicity not in
the world we live in today
absolutely not it's either one or the
other in many respects
so instead of living you know a simple
life we kind of burn ourselves to the
ground
and then we escape off on holiday which
is usually based on simplicity which is
you know laying down
out in nature and relaxing and doing
very little
it's like you know there was a quote
from a guest that i had on this podcast
a couple of years ago
i think it was when i had a chat with
the ceo
of leon the restaurant chain and he said
you should never cut down the rainforest
and then donate to the bees and this is
exactly what this strikes me as
you're cutting down your own rainforest
in order to donate to your own bees
ruining yourself so that you can raise
the funds you need to fix yourself it's
like
it feels like insanity and i'm super
guilty of this i have to admit
so one of the things that i've tried to
introduce into my life is a little bit
more simplicity
scenarios and context that simplify my
life and
every day now i go for a walk there and
back to the gym and i listen to my music
something i didn't do before i just got
an uber
and the other thing that's really helped
simplify my life is just playing with my
dog
pets like kids are amazing for
simplifying your world because they live
in such a simple world like my dog can
spend an hour absolutely amused and
obsessed by like a lucas aid bottle
or like pretending he's hunting it's
like such a remarkable thing when you
contrast it to the complexity of the
world we live in
if you're looking to simplify your world
briefly
try it if you don't have a dog get a dog
but try it
try going into their world my niece and
my dog are
fascinatingly simple and they're
unassuming
and they're unpretentious and i want to
live more in that world sometimes
and i think this is why some people are
also so incredibly obsessed with nature
all this simplicity seems to calm the
mind you know it sort of re-centers your
soul
and the next thing you see if you look
back at our ancestors and how they lived
their lives is exactly that they spent
literally all of their time
in nature that's where they lived they
lived in nature
during that i'm going to get this word
wrong right but during the mesolithic
period i got it right 12 000 years ago
they lived
nomadically in camps near rivers and
near other sort of large bodies of water
and today like a bunch of dumbass over
developed monkeys
we live in these concrete jungles alone
between four white walls
the time i spent last month for pretty
much the whole month living in the costa
rican jungle
was the most wonderful tranquil
experience of my life it was the most
human experience of my entire life
making time in nature has to be a
central part of my routine now
it's a really [ __ ] good decision
especially
for someone like me that lives in a big
busy traffic
ridden noisy chaotic city and lastly
the key thing i see when i look back at
our ancestors was
exercise and nutrition we me you us our
generation
are the most inactive sedentary group of
humans of all time according to the data
our lifestyles are gradually becoming
more and more still more sat down at our
desks
glaring into these illuminated glass
screens and office blocks
we don't need to hunt and gather anymore
right like our ancestors did which was a
huge source of their physical activity
and exercise because we've got delivery
and ubereats some guy will bring me
any food that i want to my door in 25
minutes and i'll be honest with you it's
not always good food
it's usually you know full of sugar and
artificial substances and
things like caffeine which move our mood
one way or the other
and also back then we would literally
carve and scavenge for the tools that we
needed to make our food today
amazon prime that [ __ ] will be here
tomorrow i've included this sort of
terrifying graph in my book that shows
the gradual decline of human activity
i've placed it against the graph of
obesity and sugar consumption
and it makes for a pretty alarming read
right we're not living like humans
anymore we live like
lazy gluttonous gorillas he would
increasingly rather go under the knife
on a surgeon's table to change our
appearance
than make a simple lifestyle change not
very human at all is it
so no wonder we don't feel so human
these days
if this is how you're living certainly
how i was living then you should expect
to not feel great because you're not
living in accordance with your own
natural way of being it's crazy it's
crazy that the new age cures for our
new age problems all seek to take us
back 10 000 years meditation and digital
detoxes are there to
still our mind healthy nutrition to cut
out modern junk foods
therapy friendships and human connection
to read us of the loneliness and to
connect us back to our tribe
these feelings of loneliness and anxiety
and depression
are often according to the science and
my own personal experience nothing more
than a calling
from our body to get back to our tribes
to be a little bit more human
not to find ourselves but to rediscover
who we were
who we are as humans and if you're
struggling in any way
here's some advice give it a go try and
live a little bit more human
for me as a sort of mentally busy
career-obsessed
recluse it fundamentally changed my life
i know that for sure and i genuinely
believe that it might be the thing that
could have the greatest impact on yours
okay so for the next point in my diary
i've literally just written humans have
no idea what they want which kind of
ties a little bit into my first point
but it's very very different i want to
tell you a story one of my
very very good friends i won't name him
because that doesn't matter and i keep
referencing friends on this podcast i'm
slowly losing friends so my
my circle is getting a little bit
smaller i'm just joking one of my good
friends came to my house
last week for a little bit of a catch up
and he sat on my
my sofa over there and he asked me um a
couple of questions about myself and i
turned to him and i said listen
how have you been and somewhat
instinctively as we all do
he replied yeah good and you know
when you're my mate i have to be honest
i [ __ ] hate that response
give that response to someone in like
business or when you're in a networking
event or something like that
nobody has been yeah good nobody
life fortunately and to be honest
unfortunately isn't that simple
definitely
not in the middle of a global pandemic
where our lives are locked down and
stripped back and have been completely
shifted
nobody's yeah good so i instinctively
replied to him which is a habit i've got
into recently especially with my close
friends
no how have you really been and almost
instantly
literally almost instantly he went yeah
yeah i'm pretty
burnt out to be honest with you and
that's kind of surprising because
you know i'm really lucky and i stopped
him there and the reason i stopped him
there
is because i've just spent the last
month studying the topic of burnout for
my book
and i wanted to check i wanted to check
if he like
pretty much everyone else i've ever
spoke to fit into the pattern and the
category
that almost everybody fits into when
they experience burnout
i said to him when you say you're
feeling burnt out but you're surprised
because you're lucky
what do you mean by lucky and he said
well you know because you know i've got
all the things ticked off i've got the
money
i've got the car i've got the house and
then i stopped him again and i said
that's why you're burnt out
because your own self-confessed
definition of career or life
luck and success is extrinsically purely
extrinsically motivated
and as i said in last week's podcast on
almost every occasion where someone is
doing something that they're
motivated to do by largely extrinsic or
external reasons whether it's money or
status or fame or
likes or followers or to obtain like
material objects
where the intrinsic internal rewards
like joy and personal fulfillment
a sense of purpose or a sense of
belonging are limited
you will inevitably lose your motivation
you'll struggle to get out of bed
and you'll self-diagnose yourself as
everybody seems to do
as being burnt out and let's just take a
look at the world we're living in right
now because it adds a really important
layer of context to all of that
this pandemic has robbed all of us our
lives and our work
of things that made work and our lives
intrinsically enjoyable
you know that feeling of striving
towards a shared goal the social value
of being part of a team in an office
that sense of belonging it gives you
the sense of forward motion and progress
and purpose and accomplishment
and to be honest in our personal lives
socializing and days out and family and
friends and travel
and this robber the pandemic covert 19
has left most of us
with just the work wake up zoom
to-do list sleep wake up to-do list
sleep
it's left us with just the extrinsic
stuff and to be completely honest
the only thing that makes doing a lot of
the extrinsic stuff like work worthwhile
is the promise of all the intrinsic
stuff socializing community
purpose that it promises you that it
gives us
but right now it's not giving us that
we're largely alone
not enjoying ourselves much we don't
know what the mission is
we don't know when we're going to be out
of this situation so our work feels
heavily extrinsic therefore pointless
we're doing it to pay the bills we don't
have our colleagues around us anymore
that sense of purpose and mission is
gone therefore we lack motivation
therefore we feel burnt out the more
i've tried to understand the complexity
of humans the more i've realized how
simple
predictable and alike we all are and our
motivations
don't tend to be that dissimilar with
such fragile emotional
unconscious beings that think we're
strong resilient unique
and in control we're not we're all going
through this [ __ ] together
making the same mistakes predictably
because
we all have a very very similar innate
psychological wiring
and the same psychological factors are
running the show
our working lives have been completely
knocked out of balance
and the work is just that now it's work
social chain my company the company i
founded and recently resigned from
you know it was renowned for its culture
for its sense of community for the sense
of purpose and that intrinsic pleasure
it gives the people that work there for
the joy of you know the dogs
in the office we had about 10 of them to
be honest we had a happiness team
that would make sure every day when
you're in the office you're feeling good
therapists that were there for you in
the office every single day
we had this sense of mission and purpose
that we were building this business and
forward motion
and uh it was going great because the
business was growing it still is but it
was growing and that gives you purpose
as well but when a pandemic
and a lockdown strikes all of that stuff
is taken away
all that intrinsic stuff the enjoyment
is taken away
and something that was fundamentally
designed from the ground up to give you
as much joy as a job could possibly give
you becomes
a bunch of people alone in their boxer
shorts on their own little islands
doing their to-do list every day
chatting once in a while on zoom or over
whatsapp or in
shared company groups work becomes work
nothing more that combined with the lack
of structure that everyone has in their
day now results in
long ass working hours and that has a
huge impact on your sleep and
and all of these things and all the
other problems
sends you straight into a place of
purposelessness low motivation
and when all that happens we we say it's
burnout
and i think everybody's experiencing a
bit of burnout right now
you know every year at christmas uh come
it's
widely known according to the data
companies experience the highest amount
of staff turnover because
you know as those sort of new year's
resolutions and all the introspection
occurs people decide they want to go
work somewhere else they want a new
challenge
they want something else for their lives
and we always see the same thing as
social chain
and this year we saw that behavior
happen a few months into the pandemic
quite a few people quit more than we've
ever had in the middle of the year ever
before
and part of me knows that this is
because social change pretty much every
company
lost some of its intrinsic value that
community and purpose and fun
and when it loses it and when all you
have is the extrinsic like paying the
bills a lot of people go looking for pay
rises and if you've worked at social
channel i'm telling you you can get a
pay rise it's got a good brand
people want people that have worked at
social chain and when people to
start to sort of enjoy their work less
they arrive often at the conclusion that
social change is
maybe part of the issue maybe social
change is the reason i'm not enjoying my
work as much
so they go in search of that purpose
somewhere else and people have been
leaving other companies and
in their droves to be honest and wanting
to come to social chain and people have
left social chain wanting to go
elsewhere and this is something that's
happened not in social chain alone
across every business across the whole
country so if you're feeling like [ __ ]
in your job if you're feeling a bit
burnt out if you're lacking motivation
you're feeling i know stagnant
this is probably a large part of the
reason
but going back to the conversation with
my friend which is where this this
started before i went off topic
there's another important layer to
address here my friend
like me had a relatively psychologically
rough start to life with
family issues and issues with his peers
it robbed something from his self-worth
in the same way it did for me
it made him insecure in the same way it
did for me and listen bro i know you're
listening to this because this guy
he's one of my very good friends he
never misses an episode he always gives
me great feedback i know you're
listening to this
right it takes one to no one
everything i'm saying about you could be
said about me too i too as everyone
knows
grew up with insecurities that made me
try and ball out on social media they
made me buy all the champagne and every
night club i went to made me pull up in
sports cars right
in his case it's made him particularly
intent on showing the world that he is
worthy and that he is successful the
clue of course
is in the fact that when i asked him to
define what luck or success meant to him
he said a bunch of material things
something some insecurity taught him as
it taught me
that his success would be judged by the
outside world's opinion of him
and as i said in a previous episode of
this podcast the thing that invalidates
you as a kid whether it's sort of lack
of self-worth or a lack of affection or
a lack of a sense of belonging
will be the thing you seek validation
from when you're an adult and
you know failure when both he and i were
young was not being worthy
not feeling as worthy as our peers me
for my own reasons and
him for a bunch of different reasons and
because
that was our definition of failure that
was the thing that failed us that's what
you know that was the
the worst part of our lives then our
definition of success now
is the opposite think about it if
failure then was not feeling externally
valid or valuable or worthy
success now is feeling externally valid
worthy and valuable
so we we both got big cars nice houses
lots of champagne and we proceeded to
tell and show the world
all of it i guess subconsciously in the
hope that it would
validate us and we designed our lives to
focus on achieving extrinsic externally
motivated goals like money success
status
and the science is clear on this and my
own personal experience it couldn't be
it could be clearer on this particular
topic according to the science you will
experience
less joy more despair increase your
chances of depression anxiety
and sign yourself up for a hamster wheel
existence where nothing
is ever enough of anti-climax and of
lack of purpose and if you design your
life where your north star is all of
this
sort of extrinsic meaningless [ __ ]
you're designing out
all of the things that actually
internally matter like meaningful
relationships the two are kind of
mutually exclusive
the things that you enjoy for you for
your own reasons for your own internal
sake
meaningful hobbies and passions and
subsequently the chance of being
fulfilled
happy and free from all the mental
health issues that will inevitably show
up if you live
in such an externally driven way you
know at 18 years old
as a lot of you will know i wrote in my
diary that my goal
was to buy a range rover um
i wrote there in my diary that a range
rover would be my first car
that was my goal and that was a goal
that was born out of
insecure naivety i guess
definitely a lot of insecurity and it
was a goal written because i wanted to
impress people
and i wanted girls to sleep with me
right
a goal born out of the fact that i
wanted to be validated and fulfilled
and i thought somewhere in me that a
range rover would make me feel secure in
myself
i got the range rover it was my first
car mission accomplished
it impressed people but
when you think about it it didn't make
me feel secure in myself
all it did was highlighted
but i wasn't it was the consequence of
insecurity
so paradoxically the day i achieved my
goal wasn't the day that i bought the
range rover
it was the day three years later when i
sold it
when i no longer felt that i needed it
that was the point where i was securing
myself
and that was the goal i was trying to
achieve
and you know going back to my friend for
a second you know he's
just to give you a context of how he's
working he runs his own business but he
works alone
very similar to how a freelance would
work doesn't have like a team of people
around him just kind of working alone at
home at the moment
and you know the world has done just a
phenomenal job of glamorizing the idea
of being your own boss and being a
freelancer
but nobody seems to talk enough about
how miserable this often is and
let's just factor all of the things that
i've touched on on in this podcast
up till this point about you know
extrinsic goals and the things that make
life meaningful you know the joy of
working in a team of people with a
shared mission
on work that you intrinsically enjoy
doing with as much
intrinsic motivation as possible all of
this stuff is often the absolute
antithesis of freelance work
where you often work alone without a
team on someone else's project for
someone else's purpose
just for the extrinsic reason of money
or paying the bills right
on top of that you have all of the other
[ __ ] being on japan no work life
balance no work life separation no clock
off time
i'm gonna call this freelancer
depression we're gonna try and make this
a thing freelance and depression
it's something that people who
evangelize about being your own boss and
going alone
and all of the freelance lifestyle never
seemed to mention that much
and to be fair this pandemic has made us
all freelancers to some degree it's
robbed us all of that intrinsic
rewarding stuff
i i guess i just want to i just want to
tell you one more thing
now that i've left social chain and i'm
technically unemployed
i was i sat on the sofa it was actually
yesterday with my it's actually
yesterday night before i recorded this
podcast with my assistant
and she turned to me and she asked me a
question she said do you miss all the
travelling
and the chaos of your old life and i
said to her like what do you mean
what do you mean and she said well you
know you used to be up at 3am every day
running all over the world pitching and
speaking on stage
and for a second i paused and reflected
and the thought of doing any of that
stuff now [ __ ] repulsed me
i couldn't think of anything worse but
i mean this is a big but i absolutely
used to love it i absolutely used to
love it made me so fulfilled but now
you couldn't pay me to do that and the
reason for this the reason for this sort
of monumental shift
in my mind is because when i was at
social chain i was working with people i
loved attached to a shared meaningful
purpose
and a mission and we were building
something amazing together when you
remove that and ask me if i want to run
around the world catching
five flights a week and living in hotels
50 weeks a year it seems
totally bizarre and repulsive and
pointless it seems like
such a sacrifice for nothing i would
hate to do that
and it brings me back to the moment in
my life where you know
i think i've talked about this on the
podcast before where i was technically
freelance for the first time it was
after i was 21 years old
i just exited my first startup wall park
and i hadn't started social chain yet
i was being paid i've got to be honest
with you about 70 grand a month by
companies all over the world
to help them as a consultant run their
businesses to advise their marketing
and i was in this i was in um i turned
to my mate dom
in our penthouse apartment in manchester
on the 20 we own three floors up there
i'm not bragging i'm just providing a
bit of context which i think is
important
and i told him exact quote if i go
downstairs right now and i send this one
email
i'll make 20k straight away
and i just can't find the [ __ ]
motivation to do it
and i don't know why it's 20k that's
what i said to him
verbatim exactly and the reason
was because at that point even at the
point where i was making 5k a month
consistently
something as extrinsic as a little bit
more money was not motivation enough
it would have no intrinsic material
impact on my life so the cost of walking
down
some stairs and writing an email felt
greater than the reward
but when i you know when i think about
the moment i went from being a
freelancer to when social change started
i was working with people i loved on a
shared meaningful mission
to build something [ __ ] a flight of
stairs i was flying to the ukraine at
2am on the off chance that someone might
work with us
and i did that like a dog for
seven or eight years i didn't have a
motivation problem
when i was a freelancer it wasn't a
motivation problem right as
people often sort of self-diagnose it
wasn't a lack of motivation that stopped
me walking down the stairs in my
penthouse and sending that one email
that would make 20 grand
i had a purpose problem and the same
applies to the conversation i had with
my pa you know
when i think about sprinting around the
world pitching speaking living in hotels
and sacrificing my life now
it feels so [ __ ] pointless because
i've left social chain
so i'm i guess i'm detached from the
purpose and the mission that i had then
and i i finally understand for the first
time in my life
why people who looked at my life back
then and often said to me you know
how did you do it you know why did you
sacrifice everything
are you crazy when do you sleep all of
these questions um
are you okay i used to get asked all the
time um how did you find the motivation
all the time to
to run the business and all of these
things why you know sleeping in the
office in the weekends why did you work
so hard
it all makes sense now because when i
look back
without the attachment to that mission
that i had then to me it
it looks bizarre i'm asking old stephen
why the [ __ ] did you do all of that
because right now i can't feel that
purpose so all i can feel is the
sacrifice
but i guess that's that's how you behave
i guess that's how you behave when you
have a deep sense of purpose in the work
you're doing so i guess my conclusion is
this
the answer to loving your work and being
as being the best at it which i think
that i eventually became within my
company
is working with people you love striving
towards a shared worthwhile goal
for your own intrinsically rewarding
reasons and if you can do that
i think you'll also do a pretty good job
of avoiding burnout
you'll do you'll do the work of your
life for sure like i did at social chain
and you'll remain fulfilled the whole
time
that little insight helped me so i
really hope it helps you
and so the next point in my diary is one
that i haven't fully developed yet my
thinking on so i'm kind of hoping
i can do this out loud with you together
what i've written is one of the hardest
things in life is to avoid a good
opportunity
so that you have time to devote to great
opportunities and
since i've left social chain and i'm now
technically unemployed but i have a
great reputation i have a great track
record
um i gotta be honest my inbox every day
is full of just
amazing opportunities but the amount of
time that i have every day has remained
the same
i have the same 24 hours and i'm being
bombarded with
offers and jobs and opportunities to do
this and that and the other
and i know that if i choose to accept
any of those opportunities
i'm doing it at the expense of something
else which i've talked a lot about in
this podcast
and so one of the real challenges and
one of the real sort of
talents that i'm trying to foster in
myself is being so clearly attached to
my long-term values and goals and where
i want to go and who i want to be
that i'm able to look at a really good
opportunity
whether it's financial or you know other
or status or whatever it might be or for
my personal brand or whatever it might
be
and say no now and and
to do that you have to have real faith
in yourself but you also have a
have to have a real attachment to who
you want to become and your long-term
goals
and it's something that i'm genuinely
struggling with because never in my life
as i said have i had more
people in my inbox asking me to become
directors and ceos of their companies
and offering me shares to come and help
them
and so i just wanted to share a few
things which i which i have written in
my diary about how i make the decision
and whether to take an opportunity or to
not it's fairly fairly simple the first
one as i said
is by being super clear on the person
that i want to become in the future
and the first check i can do is is doing
this opportunity going to move me closer
or further away by
costing me time to becoming that person
and the next one which i consciously ask
myself all the time now
is if i become that person that i want
to become in the future by remaining
loyal to that sort of long-term image of
who i want to become and my values
will this opportunity come back around
and for about 90 of the opportunities
about 95 percent
it will definitely come back around in
even greater abundance and value
if i become the person i want to become
and the last thing i do is i attribute a
financial value to an hour of my time
and i've read a lot about this naval's
talked about this at length as well and
philosophers and
you know people that i respect in the
business world have told me about this
as well
what you want to do is think of a really
big number for me it's about ten
thousand pounds
i say to myself that one hour of my time
is worth ten thousand pounds
and my rationale for that is based on
what i was able to create with my time
historically so you think about social
change in the business and what it
became and how much it's worth
when i go through and think about how
much each year
added to that value i can quite
comfortably say you know
a year of my time is worth say 10
million or 20 million quid and when you
think from that framework and when you
really attribute huge amounts of value
to your time you're able to cut things
out quickly that don't meet that value
it's something that i genuinely
recommend everyone does
i'm not saying attribute 10k an hour to
your time but even if it's a thousand
dollars start there say my time
one hour of my time is worth a thousand
dollars and if you think through that
lens
i swear to god the opportunities that
will come to you the ones that you'll
accept will be of
significantly more value and ultimately
that means you'll spend
more of your time more of your hours on
things of higher
value and then that's what your life
will become high value
give it a try the next point in my diary
i understand is quite a controversial
one
um i've just written marriage monogamy
and me listen
and i've spent a lot of time in this
podcast talking about relationships and
my views on marriage and the
relationship struggles that i've had and
before i say what i'm going to say i
want to appreciate the fact that this is
a completely nuanced subjective topic
but here's my thinking i'm 28 years old
and i don't know
i don't believe that marriage is the
right answer
a couple of reasons let's just start
with some fundamental principles pretty
much every
every way that i think is based on first
principles i don't think for a star
that the law and that religion have a
great track record on pretty much
anything historically and i think that
marriage is a construct that's been
passed down from one generation to
another
throughout our society without real
interrogation
because we've all done that and i can
literally predict
um the dms that i'm gonna get which
which tell me that
i'm naive and that i don't understand
which like listen
probably true right but that's the whole
point of like me
scrolling in my diary i like this to be
a two-way thing where you can just
message me and say steve you're an idiot
and you do
you guys do you i get the messages you
don't understand the world fine that's
probably true
i know it's true i don't understand
everything and that's part of the reason
i'm doing this but getting back to the
point
um for me the concept of marriage
when you look at the fundamentals of
signing and assigning this commitment
and going to a church and the
legal and religious ramifications of
some marriages
it just feels really insecure it's like
if i love someone
why do i need a contract why do i need
to go to church why do i need to get the
law involved if i
love someone what has any of that got to
do with
courts and contracts if i love someone
and if i'm secure enough
to believe that they love me too that
they won't they won't leave me
and sometimes i think it's a bit like
trapping a cat in a corner because
when you're in a marriage and when
you're in a situation which feels kind
of imprisoned or
like you can't leave um i think
issues might become somewhat magnified
right
you know the worry and the anxiety of
not being able to leave because of that
rain or that contract or because of
the way you set up your life i actually
think it might make issues bigger than
they are
and it's something that i've really
pondered you know i have a track record
in my life of really like
interrogating stuff i interrogated
school to the point that i stopped going
in university to the point that i went
to one lecture and decided that it was
a completely broken concept and i'm
starting to do the same with marriage
and people will hear different things
when i say this right largely based on
their own
opinions in life and their own
experiences and this comes from my own
experience probably largely
largely from the experience of watching
a very dysfunctional toxic marriage that
my parents had
and i'm not saying marriages can't be
brilliant some of my friends have the
best marriages some of their parents
have the most amazing marriages too
i'm just saying as a one-size-fits-all
concept
i think it needs a little bit of
questioning um
i i'm all down for the commitment i
think i'm still developing my ideas
there on monogamy but the commitment
part isn't the thing i have issue with
it's the like marriage part the law the
contract and all that nonsense
i want to talk about monogamy too
because
oh this is going to be controversial but
um i'm also
not completely convinced that we're
meant to be monogamous
i'm not completely convinced that we're
meant to have one partner
like i'm down for it because i
understand the way that the world is
wired at the moment
um but this might be the most
controversial thing i've ever saw in
this podcast
but i think if we all i think of a huge
amount of us
are honest with ourselves and this is
based on the behavior we exhibit
we would probably sleep with someone
else that was smoking heart
we don't because we value the
relationship and we don't
we know that the relationship is worth
more than
a one-night stand with someone else and
we're mature enough to
understand the consequences of our
actions but i think
if you were to anonymously poll people
and say listen would you sleep with
someone else that was hot if it had no
material impact on your marriage
i think if we're being honest with
ourselves a lot of us would but i think
99.9
of us wouldn't want our partner sleeping
with someone else and this all of this
speaks to the fact
that i'm not sure as humans
as men as women we are innately
meant to be monogamous i think that
society has played a huge role in that
i also think that over the the coming
decades i think you'll see real shifts
in this
probably not with me because i'm not
going to get to the point where i i'm
down with someone i love sleeping with
someone else if i'm
completely honest but i think it's
broken
i think marriage is broken i think like
university it's broken you know if
if i told you there was tvs for sale at
a shop on a corner but 50
of the tvs failed you wouldn't go and
buy a tv and it's the same for marriage
50 of marriages fail and if you think
about the concept of marriage
it's till death do us part but 50 of the
time it's not till death
does this part it's till that girl
slides in your dms and you meet her and
you bang her and then you you know your
marriage falls depart or
that guy slides in your dms and you go
for a coffee with him and your boyfriend
finds out and
your husband finds out he dumps you the
concept seems broken and i
but i don't know the answer i don't know
what the alternative is i know that it's
going to have to be commitment-centric
but i feel that maybe when it comes to
my life
i'm not going to seek marriage i might
try and create some kind of new age
urane
arrangement with my partner where we're
committed to each other where we have
the party the celebration which i think
is [ __ ] awesome by the way
but we don't sign all the contracts and
we remain as two separate
you know independent humans that have
come together in the middle through love
without religion or without the law
it's just an idea some of you will
disagree let me know what you think in
the comments section below or let me
know what you think in my inbox or my
my twitter because this is a super
controversial topic and it's one that
we're going to be talking about
i think next week with a very um awesome
person who is also developing
his opinion on this i don't want to give
the the
don't let the cat out the bag on this
one but trust me next week is going to
be one hell of a conversation
the last point in my diary this week is
kind of linked to a lot of the stuff
that i've said
throughout this conversation this chat
today about
extrinsically living your life through
society's image of how you should be
living
i've just written that fitting in is a
curse and the more you can be
you the more happy you will be the more
you fit into society
the less free you actually are i think
about my time in school
and you know and we've all had that
experience in school where we want to
wear the clothes everyone's wearing we
got our hair cut the same way
we listen to the music that is cool to
listen to and how like
trapped that way of living is in fact
what i've come to learn as i've gotten
older and as i've gone through life and
i've become my own person and i've taken
some of these shackles off
is the closer i've gotten to being steve
who steve
actually is the weirdo that i naturally
am and that you naturally are the
expressing myself in a way that is true
to myself in the words that i want to
without worrying about who's going to
cancel me or judge me
or my friends or friends might say you
know fake friends whatever
the more happy i've become the more
successful i've become it's made
this podcast interesting right because i
am myself there's this isn't acting this
is what i think and how i feel every
week and i don't think about the impact
of it
the closer i've got into not fitting in
to being who i
am the more happy i've become and i
think it's just something to really
reflect on because
there's so much of our lives that are
sort of imprisoned by this idea of
conformity and fitting in and being one
of the girls or being one of the lads or
you know wearing those clothes or those
shoes or being you know
being socially accepted and almost on
every occasion i can't think of one
reason
or one instance where that is an
intrinsic
intrinsically motivated thing to do and
so the science says as we've talked
about in this podcast that will lead you
to the despair the lack of joy the
depression anxiety and
and in many cases to mid-life crises
when you realize that you've been living
your life on someone else's terms for
someone else's reasons
i'm on a mission whether it's through
this podcast which is my diary my
thoughts
or whether it's through everything else
that i produce do or the work that i
pursue
whether it's how i dress whether it's
through the diary of a ceo live show
that i'm doing
to really [ __ ] be me to think for
myself and thinking for yourself isn't
easy
we think it is and this goes back to the
point of us thinking we're in control
and getting to the bottom of what your
motivations really are
i'm really really trying my my very very
best at all times to just be
steve and if there's anything that's had
a bigger
impact on my success my happiness it's
exactly that
isn't it weird when we think about our
goals for the future
we often say that we want to be x we
want to be like
x person we want to be like x thing when
really
we shouldn't aspire to be more like our
idols we should
be aspiring to be even more ourselves
the unfiltered uncaring
unassuming intrinsically motivated
version of ourselves
maybe that's the secret maybe this whole
podcast is has led to that conclusion
maybe this whole series is about that
maybe that's what life is about maybe
that's the meaning of life
maybe the meaning of life is exactly
that you start
in the womb you pop out life tells you
you are something it tells you to
conform in the classroom on the
playground
and maybe we're not just on the journey
to being more human
but we're on the journey to being
ourselves maybe that's what it's all
about
being more human
and being more like yourself
thank you so much for listening to this
episode of the diary of a ceo
listen if you're on the podcast store or
you're in spotify or you're listening to
it in some kind of app
do me a huge huge favor leave a review
and hit the subscribe button
if you're watching this on youtube right
now i need another favor i need you to
hit the like button and if you'd be so
generous to leave a comment
one person that does this will be
joining me in march at the diary of a
ceo live
show in manchester and you'll be coming
backstage and meeting me and the other
members of our team
thank you so much for listening i'll see
you again next monday
[Music]
you